[Music]
all right let's do this one last time
a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up
your dad said that he was right
now it's your turn go be a hero miles
okay
let's do this
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new spider-man into the
spider verse 2 video they just dropped a
new teaser and a big announcement about
what's going on with the movies there's
also the spider-man PS 5 clip the Sony
literally just dropped while I was
making this spider-verse video so
obviously there's a big Miles Morales
game coming out later this year based on
the Miles Morales from the first
spider-man ps4 game but this footage of
him is captured from the PS 5 version of
the game if that wasn't clear so we'll
break it down there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs so if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos will do a new Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions for spider-verse to on the
video so we'll talk about what's going
on then I'll talk about all the
different versions of spider-man that
are featured during that teaser because
that's meant to show you the different
logos of different characters that'll be
showing up during the sequel starting
with number 5 so if you didn't see the
news this past week one of the animators
on spider-man into the spider verse 2
Nick Kondo tweeted out that they had
started production on the movie this
week for those of you that saw the
teaser trailer earlier last year and
assumed that they had already been
working on the movie this whole time
that is also true what happened last
year is that Lord and Miller and the
official Spider Man Spider verse account
at Sony released a teaser to say yes the
movies happening is going to be coming
2022 that was just so nice saying that
they had started paying people to
actually start writing and developing
the sequel so this past week when this
guy said they're starting the movie he's
an animator he means that they started
to animate the movie this past week so
all the stuff up to now has just been
pre-production and then working on the
story in the script number 4 all that
spider-man PS 5 footage with the Miles
Morales game so I know a lot of people
saw this and they're like wow does that
mean that they're gonna kill off the
Peter Parker spider-man in this version
of the game no it doesn't mean that he's
going to die it just means that right
now they're doing a Miles Morales game
set mostly around hims it'll probably
involve some Peter Parker stuff because
there's still all the venom stuff that
they set up in the spider-man ps4
post-credit scene and all the ongoing
story with Peter Parker is more likely
that what'll happen with Peter Parker
during the Miles Morales game is that
he'll either be sidelined or he'll be
off working on some other problem or the
plot of the direct sequel to this game
will just be happening concur
in different parts of the city with the
Miles Morales game so think of the Miles
Morales game is more of a spin-off
franchise they could spawn its own
sequels not just a direct sequel to
Spider Man ps4 but just in terms of
where the story picks up if you haven't
played any of the expansions from Spider
Man ps4 in the post-credits scene of the
silver linings expansion you see Peter
Parker showing Miles Morales how to
web-swing just like you saw it during
the spider-verse movie I think the web
shooters are a little tight
get used to it just try to keep up
[Music]
obviously making the suit is a very big
deal just like it was during spider-man
ps4 so we'll probably get some sort of
pre credit sequence where we see miles
making his spider-man suit it looks
badass
I can't wait to play it I'll do a couple
more videos when they drop more trailers
for it and I will do giveaways for the
game when they do release it later this
year but number three some of the
biggest story changes for spider-verse
to have a lot to do with how the
characters have changed at the end of
the first movie so Miles Morales is a
really good example of that early on in
the first movie they animate the
character on what they call twos meaning
that they only animate miles at 12
frames a second to make him seem like
he's out of sync with the rest of the
universe and all the other characters
instead of animating him at a full 24
frames a second there was a stylistic
choice in service of character
development to show you how he just
wasn't fully spider-man yet he was still
trying to figure everything out then
later in the movie before the big final
battle he gains all that confidence he
knows what he wants to do and they
suddenly start animating him at a full
24 frames a second so that's why during
the big final fight all of his movements
seemed way smoother like the movement of
the original perfect quote-unquote
version of Peter Parker played by Chris
Pine at the beginning of the movie so
the start of spider-verse two miles is
already comfortable in his abilities and
they'll be animating him at a full 24
frames a second to make his movements
look much smoother much more like
classic spider-man like I am the
spider-man of this earth now the other
obvious big story change at the end of
the movie is the introduction of the
parker industries style web where risk
devices that they're all wearing so
those are based on the wrist devices
from the spider-verse comics that allow
the different versions of spider-man to
travel the web of life and destiny so
it's a little different than say like
the Avengers and Avengers end game in in
the Doctor Strange movie learning about
the multiverse in traveling through
multiple dimensions time traveling
through the quantum realm but it amounts
to the same result it's just another way
to travel the multiverse that only
spider people use when you see them
flying through the spaces between
dimensions like you see this kirby
crackle as spider-gwen gets sucked into
the multiverse you can actually see the
spiderweb strands in the background in
this cosmic space like a literal web of
life and destiny the connective tissue
between dimensions connecting everything
No
to spider-man 2099 also at the end of
the first movie it's implied that enough
time has passed since the final boss
fight the spider-man 2099 Miguel O'Hara
played by Oscar Isaac wonderfully has
given at least miles and spider-gwen the
web where risk devices to allow them to
open smaller portals between their
dimensions logically that's the only way
she'd be able to open up this portal to
peep on miles at the end just to say hi
while he's listening to music the one
that he used in the post-credits scene
to recreate that funny spider-man 67
meme was just his prototype for the
first version the number one of course
what are the other major versions of
spider-man that they're teasing based on
that intro that I added to this so
obviously Miles spider-gwen spider-man
2099 penny Parker spider-ham Jake
Johnson spider-man and spider-man noir
are all coming back in some fashion I
don't know how big those returning
characters will be during the sequel
because they're introducing other newer
versions but one of the earliest ones
that Lord and Miller officially
confirmed is the Japanese Cepeda man
from the toy a 1978 spider-man TV series
he has a really cool mech that I'm
assuming we'll see at some point during
the movie there's a logo implying that
Ben Riley's spider-man is gonna show up
there Cindy moon's logo notice the moon
above the logo here there's the 1967
original spider-man from the cartoon
series the same one from that post
credits a meme there's a logo that looks
kind of like Hopi Browns spider Punk
logo there's one that kind of seems like
cosmic spider-man's logo or captain
universe spider-man whatever you want to
call him there's a logo that seems like
it's implying the bombastic bagman
version of spider-man is gonna show up
he's the version from the Fantastic Four
spider-man crossover where he didn't
have his costume there's a logo that
kind of seems like it belongs to ghost
spider and then there's a logo that
seems like it's from spider-man from the
1990s animated TV series Lord and Miller
in the director of the movie also said
that Sony shot them down when they asked
if they could bring back Tom Holland
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield as
their versions of spider-man in the
first movie there was supposed to be a
big cameo scene with the live-action
versions coming back the Sony executives
said that they felt like it was too soon
to bring all those new live-action
versions together on screen so maybe
because four years will have gone by by
the time we get the sequel they will
feel like a
time has passed that it'll be cool but
let me know in the comments which other
versions of spider-man do you want to
see them include in some way in
spider-verse too but just a big reminder
the movie is coming out October 7th 2022
so we'll probably get another really big
trailer sometime by next year but if
they drop any more teasers or hints
about other new versions of spider-man
or what's going on with a story of
course I'll do a video about it everyone
click here for my video on all the
special deleted scenes from the first
spider-man into the spider burst movie
including those cameo scenes with Tom
Holland Andrew Garfield and Tobey
Maguire and click here for my breakdown
of that new Marvel eternals first look
teaser thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight